古典的な最適化は、古典量子アルゴリズムにおける重要なステップです。
変分量子固有値ソルバーや量子機械学習などがその例です。
しかし、最小化が難しいケースも多くあります。
高次元パラメータ空間における複雑な関数がその典型です。
私はVictoria Lipinskaです。このビデオでは、
古典量子アルゴリズムにおける古典的最適化の手法を探っていきます。
最適化問題は簡単ではありません。
パラメータの数が増えると、取り得る値の組み合わせも
指数関数的に増加していきます。
チェスを例に考えてみましょう。盤面には64マスがあり、
各プレイヤーは16個の駒を持っています。それぞれが1手指した後、
盤面のパターンは400通り。2手後は72,084通り、
3手後は約900万通り、そして
4手後には約2,800億通りにも達します。
40手まで進んだ場合、可能な局面の数は
10の120乗ほどになると推定されています。
完璧なゲームを指すには、すべての可能な局面を
探索する必要があります。この膨大な数を考えると、
すべての局面を個別に調べるのは現実的ではありません。
この問題は、2つの小さなサブ問題に分解することで解決できます。
まず、今後のゲームの展開に現れそうな
盤面の状態を特定する必要があります。
これを「注目する部分空間」と呼びましょう。
次に、その部分空間を前提として、最善手を決定します。
これを「最善手」と呼びます。
このたとえで言えば、注目する部分空間を最初に探索する作業が
古典的最適化アルゴリズムに相当します。
その部分空間が特定されると、
通常は量子アルゴリズムが最善手を見つける役割を担います。
その部分空間の中から最善を選ぶわけです。
まず、パラメータが1つだけの場合を考えてみましょう。
パラメータthetaでコスト関数をパラメータ化し、それを最適化します。
関数をプロットすると、例えばこのような形になるとします。
X軸にはパラメータthetaの値が並び、
Y軸にはコスト関数の値が表示されます。
コスト関数は、実際の財務的なコストである場合もありますし、
変分量子固有値ソルバーでよく見られるように、
自然界が最小化するエネルギーである場合もあります。
目的は、コストが最も低くなる
thetaの値を見つけることです。
thetaの初期値から始めて、最適化のステップごとに
コストをさらに下げる新しいthetaを探していきます。
グラフが見えていれば、どちらの方向に進めばよいかは直感的にわかります。
しかし最適化の難しさは、実際にはそれが見えないことにあります。
選んだthetaで関数を評価して初めて、
パズルのほんの一片、つまりコストの値がわかるだけです。
これが最適化の基本的な仕組みです。
オプティマイザーはパラメータthetaをサンプリングし、コストを計算します。
想像できるように、thetaをランダムに選んで関数全体の形を
再構築しようとするのは、あまり効率的ではありません。
そこで、賢いオプティマイザーは各ステップで
関数の勾配を求めます。
これにより、最小コストを見つけるために
グラフ上のどの方向に進むべきかがわかります。
勾配がゼロになると、アルゴリズムは終了し、
最小値が見つかったことになります。
ただし、この最小値はグローバル最小値とは限りません。
ローカル最小値である可能性もあります。
つまり、近傍ではコスト関数が最小値を取りますが、
thetaの全範囲で見ると最小ではない場合です。
パラメータが1つの場合でも、それは十分あり得ます。
パラメータの数が増えるにつれて、
関数はさらに複雑になっていきます。
パラメータが2つになるだけで曲面になりますし、
4つになるともはや描くことすらできません。
チェスの例と同様に、すべての可能性を網羅しようとすると
すぐに手に負えなくなります。
このように、高次元パラメータ空間における
複雑な関数の最小化は困難です。
それでも実用的な結果を得るためには、古典的最適化の
手法が高速かつ正確であることが求められます。
また、ノイズに対して頑健である必要もあります。
ノイズは近未来の量子コンピュータにおいて大きな影響を与えます。
古典的最適化アルゴリズムは大きく2種類に分けられます。
直接探索法と勾配ベースの手法の2種類です。
勾配ベースの手法では、最適化の過程で
関数の勾配に関する情報が必要です。
この勾配は解析的に計算することも、
有限差分計算で近似することもできます。
直接探索法は勾配情報を使わず、
別の戦略でコスト関数を最小化します。
量子コンピューティングの分野でよく使われる
最適化アルゴリズムには、次のものがあります。
COBYLAは「線形近似による制約付き最適化」の略で、
勾配を使わない最適化アルゴリズムです。
SLSQPは「逐次最小二乗法プログラミング」の略で、
勾配ベースの最適化アルゴリズムです。
SPSAは確率的な摂動ベクトルを使って、
コスト関数の近似勾配を同時に計算します。
ノイズのない環境では、COBYLAのような
オプティマイザーやSLSQPはSPSAより速く収束することがわかっています。
古典的なオプティマイザーにはそれぞれ固有のパラメータがあり、
特定のケースに合わせてステップサイズなどを指定できます。
これらのパラメータは通常、各オプティマイザーに
関連するドキュメントで確認できます。
最新の古典的オプティマイザーの比較については、
下記の参考文献リストをぜひご覧ください。
もう一つ、パラメータ化された量子 circuit の
古典的最適化に関連する現象を見ていきましょう。
先ほど見たように、コスト関数の勾配が消えることは、
オプティマイザーが特徴のない平坦な領域、いわゆる
「barren plateau（不毛高原）」に陥ったことを示している可能性があります。
barren plateauはさまざまな要因によって生じます。
ランダムに初期化されたパラメータを持つ量子 circuit に対応する
コスト関数の勾配は、
qubitの数に応じて指数関数的にゼロへ減衰します。
これは、オプティマイザーが探索する量子空間が
qubitの数の増加とともに指数関数的に大きくなるためです。
この問題に対処する方法の一つは、パラメータの数を減らし、
基礎となる空間の次元を小さくすることです。
barren plateauの問題の起源について別の見方をすると、
パラメータ化された circuit が問題に依存しない設計になっており、
指数関数的に大きなパラメータ空間に直面していることが考えられます。
対象とする問題に合わせた形で circuit を
設計することが、有効な解決策になりえます。
barren plateauを引き起こす指数的なパラメータ空間に加え、
他の物理的な現象もbarren plateauを生じさせることがあります。
量子コンピューティングの実験に伴うノイズとデコヒーレンス、
パラメータ化されたcircuitの表現能力（expressibility）、
またはモデル化されたコスト関数の非局所性とエンタングルメントの程度などです。
これらの課題への対応は、現在も活発に研究が続いています。
VQEの主要なコンポーネントを一通り確認しましたので、
次のビデオでアルゴリズム全体をまとめます。